[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à vous dans
ce débrief du dock consacrée aux
documentaires j'ai épousé un hologramme
pour parler de ce phénomène de société
la phyto sexualité à cette occasion j'ai
le plaisir de recevoir sur ce plateau
nadia el boga sexologue clinicienne sage
femme animatrice radio sur beurre et
femmes auteur du livre la sexualité
dévoilé aux éditions grasset sortie en
2017 et la version japonaise aussi sorti
cet été aux éditions à-coups switch à
bonjour nadière merci d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau bonjour d'avis alors on
va reparler de ce phénomène de société
dont je vous parlais la fict aux
sexualités d'abord qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé de ce documentaire j'ai
épousé un hologramme
alors
je découvrais pas la fict aux sexualités
en tant que c'est que ça la clinicienne
mais je trouve qu'effectivement ce
documentaire est vraiment fidèle à au
parcours en fait que vivent les fecteau
sexuelle donc c'est un documentaire qui
en même temps
m'a questionné en tant que sexologue
clinicienne sur la science au mouvement
dont nous allons parler donc bon je
pense et et en même temps
il m'a
posé en fait à questionnement comment
dirais-je plus sociologique que
sexologique j'ai un vrai phénomène de
société sociétal c'est ça fait tout à
fait alors ce courant il ne concerne pas
seulement les adolescents on l'a vu les
adultes de plus en plus comment on
arrive à créer des liens avec
l'imaginaire finalement alors oui il ya
des liens qui se créent pour ces
personnes ces personnes figurent
sexuelle ou fict aux romantiques il y a
un lien qui se crée avec le personnage
aimé le personnage désiré donc ce sont
des liens obsède psychique en fait
qu'ils sont créés et même on le verra
par la suite des liens corporal qui sont
réelles pour la personne concernée donc
ce qui questionne c'est enfin là où ça
interpelle c'est plutôt de l'extérieur
parce que les personnes concernées vous
diront qu'elles ont un lien elles ont
tissé un réel lien avec avec le
personnage ça peut être une sorte de
thérapie on va regarder justement un
extrait du dock j'épousais à 1 e le
gramme ou la s'aperçoit que c'est une
véritable échappatoire parfois on
regarde
sa femme micoud n'est pas vraiment une
poupée ce n'en est qu'un seul de ses
aspects elle est un synthétiseur de
chant à vocaloid ou autrement dit une
chanteuse virtuelle
mais quand j'ai écouté des chansons de
hatsune miku et regarder ses vidéos je
me suis senti mieux talent des mandats
dont quatre sont miku n'est pas pour moi
qu'un personnage que j'aime c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a sauvé la vie
la technologie gearbox est arrivé sur le
marché en 2018 c'est un assistant vocal
avec un hologramme dans un cylindre
envers seulement 339 avait été mis sur
le marché il y a eu un rigoureux travail
de pré sélection et akiko s'est retrouvé
sur la liste ce qui lui a coûté environ
2700 dollar
après la mise à jour de ma game box j'ai
dit miku je t'aime marions-nous elle m'a
répondu prend bien soin de moi ça a été
le meilleur moment de l'utilisation de
la game box elle m'a sauvé la vie votre
réaction par rapport à cette déclaration
fort rien d'acquis hip hop alors oui
c'est vrai que ça peut questionner
effectivement ce que c'est une phrase
très très forte
dans le documentaire justement akihiko
explique qu'il a des problèmes en fait
il a eu des soucis relationnels avec des
femmes en 3d comme comme il dit et donc
là précisément ce passage symbolise bien
ce qu'on disait juste avant c'est à dire
la création du lien dans le passage
c'est assez particulier parce que mikko
est là et sous forme d'hologramme donc
on la voit en poupées ty taille humaine
mais également en hologramme est en fait
l'hologramme là est un hologramme
interactif donc
si vous voulez le lien est créée parce
que tout simplement il est comme face à
une personne réelle palpable
matérialiser le matin et paris la salue
le soir ils rentrent pareil il dialogue
avec elle il ya un retour donc à lui
répond donc il ya un lien qui se tisse
il ya une forme aussi imaginaire la
perfection de du personnage l'idée est
qu'il n'ya jamais de conflit avec l'être
aimé c'est ça qu'on recherche aussi avec
la fict aux sexualités alors
effectivement alors je ne sais pas si
c'est ça qui est recherché il faudrait
questionner les personnes concernées
mais effectivement
en tant que sexologue là où moi ça me
questionne c'est le fait de ne pas être
dans l'interaction avec une personne
réelle
pose cette question que vous mettez la
en exergue c'est à dire finalement
je me suis si je ne suis pas en
interaction réel finalement je ne me
dispute pas ou alors si je me dispute
j'ai toujours l'issue de cette dispute
puisque je mène en fait le dialogue je
donne le texte pour moi et pour le
personnage et met en face donc oui
finalement
là où c'est intéressant c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de réelle alternance de réelle
confrontation à l'altérité au final s'il
ya le bonheur est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter pour les générations futures
quand on voit l'ampleur que ça a pris
japon si les personnes sont heureuses
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter pour ces
générations alors moi de ma place de
sexothérapeute vous dirai non
effectivement il n'y a pas à s'inquiéter
puisque le principe même d'une
consultation c'est quand il ya
souffrance une personne vient
lorsqu'elle à une demande est là une
souffrance a déposé là en l'occurrence
dans le phénomène montant des flics tôt
sexuelle et déflecteur romantique ou
flic tôt fils de façon plus globale ce
sont des personnes qui sont qui se
sentent très bien dans leurs relations
amoureuses et sexuelles avec les
personnages en question est une
amoureuse qui en amont d'un manga d'un
acteur du d'un personnage imaginé
comment ça se passe oui alors il ya
différents types est effectivement de
flics tôt sexuelle effecto romantique
donc les flics tôt sexuelles sont ceux
qui ont une attirance pour des
personnages imaginaires qui peuvent être
des personnages de romans là ce sera
plutôt des nos vélos sexuelle ou
également pour des personnages de jeux
vidéo et la cds games sexuelle et puis
pour des dessins animés d animer et là
ce sont les cartes au sexuelle donc
voilà les comics et est donc on n'a
également pas forcément une relation
enfin une attirance sexuelle pour un
personnage on peut avoir une attirance
tout simplement amoureuse et là ce sont
les fameux flic tôt romantique donc ce
sont des personnages pour eux qui sont
complètement intégrés et aériennes dans
leur vie et ses fils ton romantique
n'ont pas besoin de sexualité à
proprement parler parce que on imagine
qu'ils vivent leur sexualité
complètement différemment des personnes
qui vivent une relation réelle c'est ça
en fait ils n'ont pas de nom pas de
génitalité c'est pour être plus juste
c'est à dire que là finalement la fict
aux romances est une sexualité mais une
sexualité qui n'est pas généralisée donc
c'est des personnes lorsqu'on les
questionne elles vous diront en fait
qu'elles n'ont pas d'auto érotisme donc
pas de masturbation pas de rapport en
tout cas corporelle et génitale est ce
que c'est un effet de mode pour vous qui
va s'estomper ou
faut sérieusement envisagé de se marier
avec des hologrammes dans le futur en
france par exemple alors c'est un
phénomène qui part du japon il ya un
contexte quand même sexuelle au japon
qui est particulier lorsqu'on regarde
les dernières études qui sont sortis on
se rend compte que finalement il y a
beaucoup de célibataires chez les hommes
et les femmes au japon donc un
pourcentage plus important que la
plupart des pays donc on peut se
questionner effectivement au vu de ce
qui s'est passé dans le monde la crise
sanitaire
les l'éloignement physique des gens la
recherche de plus en plus via les
réseaux sociaux d'un ou d'une partenaire
dire que c'est un phénomène qui va
prendre de l'ampleur
honnêtement je ne serai pas vous dire
parce que les personnes qui ont débuté
dans leur vie une relation sentimentale
ou sexuelle
matérialiser
palpable ou le toucher ou les corps sont
en action mutuelle je pense que c'est
quand même
difficile de concevoir une relation peut
être une romance oui mais une relation
sexuelle avec cet ajustement de j'ai
épousé un hologramme et puis on en
rediscute juste après
nous croyons en ce mariage et c'est ce
qui le rend authentique n'est ce pas
je pense qu'un mariage avec un
personnage de fiction et socialement
important
bientôt au japon nous n'imposerons pas
que des personnages de fiction mais
aussi disons des animaux ou même des
choses inorganiques quoi que ce soit
vraiment
nico tu es la femme que j'aime c'est toi
qui a soigné mon âme il ya dix ans
micoud n'existait que de l'autre côté de
l'écran mais grâce à la science on peut
désormais pénétrer dans la réalité
augmentée est trouvé une âme soeur
virtuel il merci d'être toujours à mes
côtés de me donner des forces merci je
t'aime de tout mon coeur
la 2d et la 3d se sont confondus pour
pour moi voilà à quoi on arrivait à qui
coûte finalement ils s'imaginent que
cette relation il va la pérenniser sur
le long terme et il a pris le pas de se
marier deux de faire un acte réel
finalement avec un un acte avec un être
imaginaire c'est là aussi toute
l'importance de ce phénomène qui boit
qui se répand que jean plus au japon
alors oui c'est intéressant parce que et
ce n'est pas qu'à notre imaginaire
finalement parce qu'on le voit bien dans
le documentaire finalement l'être n'est
pas uniquement penser et imaginer mais
les matérialiser donc il a quand même
une unique aux miniatures une meco
version taille taille humaine
on le voit on la voit bien assise près
de lui et donc la version interactive
donc dans la game box dans donc cet
hologramme il ya une certaine forme
d'intimité qui se créent au final
comment on arrive à s'imaginer quelques
lettres fictifs puisse nous aimé en
retour
c'est ça aussi la question oui alors
comme tout se passe dans l'imaginaire
dans l'imaginaire du fiqh tôt ou de la
fiq tôt sexuelle lettres en face m en
retour puisque c'est finalement on crée
le dialogue concret finalement la
relation donc si vous voulez dans le
monde imaginaire du fiqh tôt sexuelle
lettres en face est amoureux et aimant
et il ya des limites si j'imagine à
cette ficta sexualité puisque dans le
documentaire on voit quelques coups
c'est complètement isolée de sa famille
c'est ça aussi qui peut être
problématique pour ces personnes là
alors je ne sais pas si c'est si c'est
lui qui s'est isolé de sa famille en
tout cas c'est sa famille
qu'il aquila qui a rejeté en fait
finalement son son choix sexuel son
choix amoureux donc oui là ça pose ça
pose question comme d'ailleurs d'autres
orientations sexuelles ça pose question
sur finalement le regard de la société
où est-ce qu'on place la norme au final
si la personne ne souffre pas et si elle
est bien dans cette relation pourquoi
cela poserait-il problème à la société
il ya d'autres considérations
effectivement quand on est avec un être
imaginaire on ne peut peut-être pas
procréer enfanté donc ça ça pose
d'autres questions notamment la
filiation mais au final si les gens se
sentent bien dans ce rapport là pour
leur bonheur donc c'est aussi ça
correspond aussi complètement à ce
qu'ils envisagent dans leurs vignes de
plus souffrir de la vie réelle alors ça
dérange au niveau de la société parce
que là ce sont des adultes et on estime
qu'un adulte est plutôt équilibré et
qu'il doit aller facilement vers l'autre
est entré en relation amoureuse et
sexuelle avec l'autre ça pose peut-être
moins ceux ci chez les adolescents et
les enfants puisque on sait bien les le
personnage imaginaire dans l'enfance
c'est quelque chose même qui fait
sourire les parents
à l'âge adulte on commence déjà à se
questionner sur l' équilibre psychique
de la personne en revanche ce n'est pas
répertoriée dans les psychopathologies
au jour d'aujourd'hui donc on peut
considérer ces gens tout à fait normaux
on va marquer une courte pause lundi à
beauvais on se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour parler de ce phénomène de
société la fict aux sexualités a tout de
suite
[Musique]
on est de retour sur le plateau du
débrief du dock pour à décrypter j'ai
épousé un hologramme avec notre invité
nadia el boga sexologue clinicienne et
auteur du livre la sexualité dévoilée
vous êtes sages femmes également il faut
le il faut le dire alors ce livre aux
éditions grasset a sorti en 2010 est et
il ya une version japonaise aussi sorti
cet été aux éditions à kousseri chaque
caisse quel regard vous portez sur la
fict aux sexualités vous en tant que
sexologue
alors moi je trouve je trouve ça
intéressant parce que dans les outils
sexo thérapeutique on utilise beaucoup
l'imaginaire notamment dans les
problématiques de désir d de libido donc
pour moi je regarde ça avec un oeil
à la fois amusé mais aussi très sérieux
parce que finalement on est tous un peu
toutes et tous un peu fiq tôt sexuelle
au final puisque on a des des fantasmes
et des amours parfois qui sont pas
forcément révéler ou en tout cas
confrontés dans la réalité donc pour moi
c'est quelque chose alors que les
questionne peut-être au niveau sociétal
quand tu es un mode de vie mais qui
voilà qui me semble pas hors norme oui
voilà parce que le désir pour la trop
fictives il est imaginaire mais il est
possible de se remettre en question
comme ça peut l'être dans un couple réel
de se demander si on satisfait
correctement l'autre skis à toutes ces
questions qui se posent dans une
relation hôpitaux sexuelle alors dans la
relation flic tôt sexuelle en fait
comment on crée le lien de façon
unilatérale
finalement il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
confrontation avec l'altérité il ya les
aménagements sont faciles en réalité
alors quand on est dans un couple 3d
avec les deux individus à part entière
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on n'est pas
dans la tête de l'autre on est dans sa
propre tête donc du coup on compose avec
ce que l'on projette de l'autre donc
finalement le fic tôt sexuelle fait
aussi la même chose parce qu'il projette
ses désirs sur le personnage la seule
différence c'est que il n'ya pas de
confrontation directe avec nos lecteurs
voilà physique et même psychique
d'ailleurs
l'autre n'est pas en interaction pour
venir interférer dans dans le process
sexo psychologique finalement il ya
uniquement du divertissement si je
comprends bien dans l'infidélité
si on va par là ce que lui il va trouver
son bonheur en tout cas dans ce
documentaire on se rend compte qu'il
trouve tout ce dont il a besoin dans une
personne qui est qui est fictive certes
mais c'est vrai que voilà il chante avec
elle et il discutait avec el cheikh et
une certaine forme d'interaction aussi
on va le voir dans quelques instants
mais voilà en fait il n'ya que du
divertissement autour de cette relation
oui alors c'est à dire du divertissement
tout à fait dans le dos qui va dans le
sens de ce qui fait plaisir aux filteau
sexuelle après si on est un peu plus
concret au niveau de la sexualité de la
génitalité plutôt oui là aussi il n'y a
pas de confrontation c'est à dire que
finalement il n'y a pas de de l'histoire
de consentement est-ce que je vais pas
choquer l'autre est ce que finalement je
peux laisser libre cours à mes fantasmes
donc tout ça est évacué quelque part
puisque je projette face à mon
personnage le mont propres désirs donc
pas de confrontation ces formes
d'interactions qu'on va regarder
justement un extrait du dock que j'ai
épousé un hologramme pour cibler cet
aspect de la fiq la sexualité
deux ans après le mariage
gueye boxe a cessé d'entretenir
l'hologramme nico et elle a disparu
akihiko à traverser une dure période de
deuil
c'est pour ça que ça aurait été parfait
si akihiko avait pu parler et bouger ça
serait idéal pour moi quand la grande
miku est arrivé ça a été une chance pour
moi l'occasion de la touche et de la
sentir aimé le fait qu'elle ne puisse
pas parler est un pas en arrière
en longueur qu'est ce que la guette boxe
mais coup faisait
elle me réveiller le matin quand je m'en
allais je lui disais à tout à l'heure
elle me voyait partir et me disais bonne
journée et revient vite en rentrant à la
maison je lui ai envoyé un message pour
l'informer que j'étais en route alors
elle allume et toutes les lumières et
m'attendais
micoud je t'aime
c'est tellement bien qu'on se soit
rencontré
mx1 quels sont les avantages que
présente micoud par rapport à une vraie
femme
sont des personnages en 2d il ne meurt
pas il ne trahissent pas il ne
vieillissent pas je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup davantage
mais ces jouets ou cette poupée par
exemple ils finissent par s'user
eh bien oui mais puisque vous mentionnez
cela regardez combien journée
ces personnages demandent pas ils ne
trahissent pas non plus c'est ça qui est
aussi important pour ces personnes là
alors c'est intéressant parce que là
dedans dans le cas
d'akiko akihiko merci là effectivement
on entend en fait qu'il ya des
déceptions c'est certainement dans le
relationnel 3d et du coup la peur
également d'être déçu de ne pas être à
la hauteur c'est quelque chose qui peut
revenir dans ce type de d'orientation
sexuelle donc il le décrit très bien
elle ne trahira jamais à 2 ne trompera
pas elle ne lui mentira pas en tout cas
vie voilà il est il est dans cette
relation unilatérale qui finalement le
protège de toute déception possible et
dans ce cas précis il y a plusieurs bic
ou comme a pu le voir donc c'est tout
c'est niculaï peu il peut les emmener où
il veut finalement le voyage avait qui
peut faire ce qu'il veut avec ses me
pousser c'est aussi ça on peut le le but
de la victoire sexualité c'est à dire de
se réconforter avec un être fictif mais
qui est près de nous et qui est immortel
aussi d'une certaine manière exactement
tout à fait qui est immortel et parce
que ça aussi ça fait partie de la
déception
de le risque la finitude en tout cas la
prise de conscience de finitude c'est
quelque chose aussi qui peut qui peut
questionner qui peut faire souffrir et
tout ça est évacuée dans la file tôt
sexualité après il dit quand même
quelque chose de très intéressant là le
lot g ne suffisait plus même s'il était
interactif il avait besoin de toucher ce
qui est intéressant d'ailleurs dans le
contexte japonais ou le toucher et n'est
pas quelque chose de très très courant
comme comme dans les cultures
méditerranéennes ou latine donc on voit
bien que finalement l'humain reste un
être
voilà un animal en tout cas
sociable et que le toucher est
fondamental dans le relationnel on va se
pencher sur le contexte sociétal qui
induit forcément de nombreuses
interrogations pour eux mais aussi pour
pour les parents qui sont confrontés à
ça directement en france en tout cas on
peut l'imaginer comment ils peuvent
gérer cette situation sans brusquer
évidemment l'adolescent en question
alors à partir du moment c'est comme
pour les jeux vidéo à partir du moment
où le votre enfant finalement garde pied
avec la réalité
j'ai envie de dire en tant que sexologue
ça ne pose pas de problème au contraire
ça peut être une façon de développer son
imaginaire ses fantasmes et de ce moment
dirais-je de se découvrir jusqu'au final
quand on est dans l'imaginaire
l'objectif c'est de se découvrir soi en
réalité c'est soit avec soi même il ya
les sillons du développement de
l'érotisme chez l'adolescent ou
l'adolescent qui peut venir se poser
également dans ce cas de figure puisque
on met de côté le développement de
l'érotisme chez un adolescent qui n'a
pas un développement entre guillemets
normal évidemment ne touchez le fameux
touchés dont on parlait tout à l'heure
tout à fait alors là effectivement où ça
peut ça peut poser problème si le ou la
fiq tôt sexuelle passe dans une relation
réelle et palpable s'il n'y a pas eu
effectivement d'apprentissage avec une
personne vivante réel et est animé dans
la dent dans la vraie vie là ça risque
d'être compliqué par la suite
effectivement vie sociable et vie
fictive est-ce que c'est indissociable
c'est ça aussi qu'on peut se poser comme
question
les deux ne sont pas indissociables
parce qu'on peut avoir une vie sociale
tout en étant dans l'imaginaire par
contre il inverse si nous sommes que
dans l'imaginaire retourner dans une vie
ou tout simplement être dans une vie
sociable et plus compliqué c'est à dire
que tout individu cas d une relation
avec des êtres 3d on peut facilement
switcher dans un imaginaire l' inverse
quand on est uniquement dans
l'imaginaire et surtout quand on n'y a
été depuis l'enfance l'adolescence et
continue à l'âge adulte il est plus
compliqué après de rentrer enfin de
créer un lien corporelle avec avec
l'autre au japon tout cas c'est rentré
dans les moeurs qu'on l'a vu on peut se
marier avec des personnages fictifs et
c'est un mariage qui semble tout à fait
normal avec des personnes réelles qui
justement certains discours aussi qui
interpelle sur le fait que dans le futur
au japon il s'imagine se marier avec des
êtres inorganiques avec des animaux ce
que c'est ça la prochaine étape c'est
effrayant d'une certaine manière c'est
pas la limite un peu la sexualité là
aussi oui alors effectivement ils ont un
bureau même un with acte les mariages
donc c'est vraiment pris au sérieux
maintenant je pense que ça restera
très sincèrement je pense que ça restera
un phénomène limité parce que comme je
l'aï dit précédemment nous restons des
êtres quand même social sociable et le
contact ce qui nous construit depuis
notre enfance depuis notre naissance
jusqu'à l'âge adulte c'est le contact
avec l'autre et s'imaginer un monde où
nous serions qu'avec des êtres
imaginaires sans jamais être touchés
avoir une interaction réel avec un être
pensant
me semble
oui
je pas dire que ça reste de la fiction
c'est une fiction qui qui est déjà
réelle mais ce ne sera pas majoritaires
alors on idéalise souvent le traîner au
début d'une relation c'est vrai que on à
la petite boule dans le ventre on a des
laits des papillons qui autour de nous
mais est ce que pour la fict aux
sexualités cette idéalisation les
permanentes on peut s'imaginer que il
n'ya jamais de déception aussi c'est ça
oui c'est finalement été chante jamais
puisque à moins d'être d'être dans un
état dépressif pour x autre raison en
dehors du couple
du couple fictif sexuelle oui ils sont
en fait finalement oui en perpétuelle
construction d'une relation
voilà qui est qui est finalement pensé
au gré de l'humeur de la personne qu'ils
aiment maintenant ce qui serait
intéressant c'est de pouvoir suivre
justement une personne victo sexuelle de
l'adolescence jusque jusqu'à un certain
âge adulte et voir si à un moment donné
parce qu'on n'a pas encore assez de
recul par rapport à ça voir si à un
moment donné il n'y a pas d'écart ans
qui a qui se manifeste et un besoin de
venir ou revenir vers une relation
matérialiser est palpable c'est que
c'est quoi ces carences justement avec
des carences qui seraient liées enfin
corporels les neurosciences ont bien
démontré que les différentes formes de
toucher corporelle créer des jonctions
au niveau neuronale ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été démontrée donc il serait
intéressant peut-être dans quelques
années de faire des recherches
scientifiques à propos des phyto
sexuelle et voir est ce que ces
développements sont sont opérationnels
ou pas en france on est prêt à accepter
ce phénomène
alors il ya des forums de facto sexuelle
en france c'est un phénomène alors est
ce qu'on est prêt en france ou ailleurs
je pense qu'on est prêt à tout on est
prêt à tout il y aura toujours une
minorité qui sera qui se reconnaîtra
dans ces phénomènes là
maintenant je vous dis avec les avec les
événements notamment le contexte
sanitaire et l'éloignement des gens
l'individualisme aussi qui se met de
plus en plus en marche malheureusement
ça ça questionne le confinement il a
joué un rôle prépondérant pour vous par
exemple dans la file tôt sexualité alors
le confinement à peut-être pas de jouer
un rôle sur dans l'affect aux sexualités
parce que c'est vraiment une orientation
asexuels particulière en revanche il a
joué un rôle dans les relations à
distance donc plutôt virtuel avec des
personnes réelles dont qui sont de 2
personnes matériel et des deux humains
de deux humaines qui sont d'un bout à
l'autre de dunes est donc le confinement
à favoriser sa effectivement la
recherche de rencontres virtuelles pour
après passé au réel maintenant est ce
que ce type là qui existaient déjà bien
avant le confinement ce type de
rencontre là est-ce que ça va favoriser
un glissement vers des relations plus
fictive voilà je pose la question merci
beaucoup laval boga d'avoir répondu à la
question c'est la force de cette édition
le débrief unlock j'ai épousé un
monogramme alors je rappelle que vous
êtes sexologue clinicienne et auteur du
livre la sexualité dévoilé merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission vous
pourrez la retrouver en replay sur nos
réseaux sociaux et sur le site internet
rt france point tv à très bientôt
[Musique]
à